we have new information this morning on
the attacks around atlanta that killed
eight people on tuesday including six
asian women the suspect 21-year-old
robert long
is charged with murder and aggravated
assault but one police spokesman is
taking criticism for his public response
as investigators say they are not sure
if the attacks targeted
asians mark straussman is in cherokee
county georgia for us outside the spa
where the rampage began
mark good morning to you good morning
tony this is where it began where
four people were killed two of them
asian women the suspect robert long
told police he's a sex addict not a
racist
but there are plenty of people who
believe that this was a hate crime
robert long's parents recognized him in
these surveillance photos posted on
social media
and alerted deputies who began tracking
his cell phone
they forced his suv off the highway and
arrested him
150 miles south of atlanta but not
before they say he went on a rampage
at three different atlanta area spas a
white male what is he wearing
i don't know eight people were murdered
in roughly one hour
six of them asian women this is still
early but he does claim that it was not
racially motivated
officials said race did not appear to be
behind the attacks
he apparently has an issue what he
considers a
fiction and sees these locations as
something that allows him to go to these
places and
it's a temptation for him that he wanted
to eliminate the working theory is a
sexual addiction issue rather than a
a racial profile during our interviews
we asked that specific question
and uh and that did not appear to be the
motive
but activist and author helen zia said
authorities are
missing important context hyper
sexualization
of asian american women is part of the
racism
toward asian americans and to say that
sexual
addiction is an excuse or a reason to go
on a mass killing rampage is ridiculous
he's going to take the word
of a mass shooter who happens to be
white against
the lived experience of the asian
american community
zia also said captain jay baker's
description of the suspect's frame of
mind
was outrageous he was pretty much fed up
and
kind of end of his rope and yesterday
was a really bad day for him and this is
what he did
i couldn't believe that the police
captain was
recounting the bad day that the killer
had without a shred of empathy for the
really bad day that the eight victims
and their families had the incredible
grief that
the whole community is going through and
this is the kind of thing that makes
people question law enforcement
and whether they are really there for
the people that they're supposed to be
protecting
captain baker is also under attack for a
anti-asian facebook post uh he
of his last year he talked up t-shirts
that said
covent 19 imported virus from china
we reached out to the cherokee county
sheriff's office for a comment
but we have yet to hear back gail thank
you mark
that was a moment i have to say when i
was watching that news conference and he
called it a bad day and all i could
think of was
eight people are grieving tonight it's a
guy that had an issue he blames a race
of people for his problem
and then he goes and eliminates what he
thinks to eliminate the temptation
that he has an issue with it's
outrageous it's a peculiar amount of
empathy for
a mass shooter it's humanizing the
shooter it's humanizing the shooter once
again
yeah and can i point out that the
shooter is a white man who is alive
after they knew that he had killed eight
people and he was armed and he was armed
and they knew that too